[Music]
is
well good afternoon evening whatever we
be
welcome welcome welcome to those of you
that are with us online we want to
welcome you and hope that you will just
participate at home in this worship
service
let's pray
father we love you we're so thankful
that your mercy surrounds us
that your grace embraces us that your
love infills us
thank you for this opportunity to come
together and to just express
our thanksgiving to you
our worship of you together
thank you lord that you enlighten our
hearts thank you lord that you that you
fill us with a revelation of your
presence at all times
thank you jesus we love you and welcome
you amen
well let me make an announcement or two
here quickly today is our first sunday
meal after the long reprieve we've been
on so we will
ask you if you'd like to meet us at the
hat creek burger
just down the road a piece it says just
down the street here
after our service tonight for a meal
there's playground for the kiddos and
we'd love to connect so please come out
marilyn and i will be there shaking
hands welcoming people
trying to mooch a drink or something
and then the state of the table
that's the church family meeting that's
going to be happening on sunday march
the 20th that's two weeks from now right
after the service at 6 15 p.m
it's a chance for us to catch everyone
for yeah catch everyone up on everything
from year end goals to leadership
transitions to finances amen
thank you jesus
well i've already prayed so would you
like to worship with us
i see i got out of order on the pla
praying i apologize next time i'll pay
more attention to the schedule
marilyn's throwing you under the bus
thank you i do appreciate that even out
of order it was great
um why don't you guys stand with us
we're going to get started on our
worship um
jesse's going to start us out and i just
want to invite you guys into the space
with us
sing along for the songs that you know
and if you don't um i just invite you to
do what feels most natural for you to
connect with what's going on inside of
you in your heart with what god might be
speaking or saying to you
um or just checking in
there is so much freedom and space
in this room and together in this
community for who you are and your story
and what you bring to
to the table the literal table um the
metaphorical table whichever one
so anyways we love you guys and we want
y'all to enter into the space with us
[Music]
and my hope is in you
only
in my heart you hold
cause you made this sin
holy
[Music]
cause your glory is so beautiful
i've fallen to my knees
[Music]
in the heartbeat of my life
is to worship in your life
cause your glory is so
[Music]
so beautiful
life is yours my hope is
[Music]
holy
cause your glory is so beautiful
[Music]
i fall until my
my knees
is to worship in your life cause your
glory is so beautiful
your glory is so beautiful
[Music]
hallelujah
jesus
[Music]
is
more
[Music]
sing that together
glory glory
hallelujah
jesus
[Music]
you are good and we can trust you
we can trust you with our emotions
with our failures and flies god we can
be vulnerable with you
knowing that there is complete love
unconditional
unmerited
fully loved
god would you use this space in this
time right now to rewrite the narratives
in our minds
that would tell us a different story
would you use the space to speak truth
to our hearts
to remind us of who we are in you
god we turn our ears in our hearts
towards you
we want to hear what you have to say
[Music]
here's my heart
lord
[Music]
speak
what
is my heart
[Music]
is my heart lord
he's my heart
lord
he is
[Music]
i am yours
i am
loved i am
[Music]
breathe he is
is
i am
[Music]
you are sure
you are alive
[Music]
my heart
is
he
[Music]
is my heart
speak
what is true
[Music]
is
always true
[Music]
you are here
you are
[Music]
is
true
speak what is true
[Music]
would you guys join me in the prayer of
the people we'll read this along
together and then feel free to lift up a
name or situation that's on your heart
and also to those of you joining us
online feel free to leave something in
the comments
jesus for the city of saxi texas and for
every city and community and all of
those who live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the old and the sick
for the widow and the orphan
for the injured and suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and for all who remember
and care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us
and that you hear us
and so we lift these names and
situations up to you
do
the parker family
health recovery
angelina
for these names and moments that we have
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light
healing and hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
let's lift up this song on behalf of
ourselves and those that we're carrying
let's believe that god has the best in
store
[Music]
in the presence of my enemies
now raise it hallelujah
louder than the unbelief
[Music]
for me
and now i'm gonna
see gonna hear
[Music]
hope will arise
hallelujah
with everything inside of me
[Music]
i raise a hallelujah
mystery
now razor hallelujah
feel you lost
[Music]
is
louder and louder
[Music]
death is defeated
the king is alive
[Music]
sing a little
we're louder sing a little louder
[Music]
is
louder
[Music]
louder and louder
[Applause]
[Music]
is
hallelujah
[Music]
yes god
we believe that you're with us in the
trenches
when we're fighting even against
ourselves
even against the voices and the lies in
our head
you're there
with your truth
with your light
would you break through our darkness god
and will we step into your light
in this season of lent god would you
help us
to grab onto the light would you help us
to give up the things
that pull us away from you
and to grab on to the goodness
to the glory
the redemption
the forgiveness
the beauty of the gospel
that calls us to more that calls us to
love
that calls us to life
we love you god
and we're grateful for this time
together
keep speaking to us
it's in your name i pray amen
thank you guys so much would you all go
ahead and sit down and turn to the
people around you welcome them make them
feel at home and then brett will get
started
good evening grace and peace
welcome to the table my name is brett
and it is
super d-duper
good to be with you all
i was i was practicing this message and
i got to a certain point of emphasis
and i was like it's so
my grasp i was literally said as i was
practicing super d duper important and i
was like brett you can't say that bud
you cannot say super that is not cool at
all
so i thought i'd just open with it
um
well um
welcome
welcome to the table really really glad
that you're here and that of course
includes those joining us online love
you lots
and and everyone who is new here kind of
you know making their way into the
community um whether it's your you know
well sometimes it can just take a while
even if it's your like fifth sixth
eighth time you know it's kind of like
all right feeling it out feeling it out
so um yeah we're just really really glad
that you're with us and we long to be um
just an inclusive
community inclusive space where um
people can
be their full selves and feel at ease
you know that's that's really our goal
so
i'll just say i'm really glad that
you're here
so we are actually beginning a new
series tonight uh titled lent at the
table
and uh the the season of lent in in the
christian context it is of course not
that stuff you get out of your dryer
trap uh in in christian faith this is
the season of preparation spiritual
preparation heart soul preparation uh as
we um approach uh good friday that is
the day of the cross and then a few days
later easter sunday so um it's 40 days
not including sundays so um
if you were here for our ash wednesday
service i know a number of you were
that kind of kicked off our linton
season and often people will do one of
two things they will um kind of fast in
some way like give something up let
something go um
kind of just as a as a form of sacrifice
sometimes it can be like a bad habit or
it can also just be something you really
it's like oh i just love that thing um
but it's sort of uh it's a letting go
and um so they'll often let something go
and and or take something up like a new
practice uh a new spiritual discipline
whether it's you know reading the
scriptures or praying every day or you
know there's all sorts of things so at
any rate you are welcome to to join us
in that we'd love for you to to join in
if you uh feel so led so um
kind of with that the the title of my
message tonight
is a mysterious cosmos a mysterious
cosmos we're gonna be in the gospels uh
a whole lot uh and specifically the
gospel of luke um that tells the the
jesus story and uh so tonight we're
gonna be in luke chapter four uh verses
1 through 13
and this is the the famous story of
jesus the temptation of christ by the
devil so um let's go ahead and begin
with with this reading from luke chapter
four
it says jesus
full of the holy spirit left the jordan
and was led by the spirit into the
wilderness
where for forty days he was tempted by
the devil he ate nothing during those
days
and at the end of them he was hungry
the devil said to him if you are the son
of god tell this stone to become bread
jesus answered and by the way there's a
lot of each time jesus is responding
he's quoting scripture and in a moment
the devil will be doing the same which
is kind of an interesting thought of
satan quoting the bible
um
yeah okay that could be tangent so i
won't chase it um
jesus answered his written man shall not
live on bread alone verse 5 the devil
led him up then to a high place and
showed him in an instant all the
kingdoms of the world
and he the devil said to him jesus i
will give you all their authority and
splendor it has been given to me and i
can give it to anyone i want to if you
worship me it will all be yours
jesus answered it is written
worship the lord your god and serve him
only
the devil led him to jerusalem had him
stand on the highest point of the temple
if you are the son of god he said throw
yourself down from here for it is
written
this is now the devil quote in the
scriptures he will command his angels
concerning you to guard you carefully
they will lift you up in their hands
that you will not strike your foot
against a stone jesus answered
it is said do not put the lord your god
to the test
when the devil had finished all this
tempting he left him until an opportune
time
so tonight i've got basically just three
things uh three things i'd like us all
to remember and although i won't be
quoting like directly very often from
this whole passage i think as i go
you'll be able to tell it's very much
kind of in the background
of everything i'm i'm going to be
speaking about tonight so uh so here's
the three things to remember we'll start
with this first one remember
that you we live in not a dead cosmos
uh but a profoundly spiritual and
mysterious
place
remember we live in not a dead cosmos
but profoundly spiritual and mysterious
place you know for many christians or i
should say modern christians um kind of
immersed in our secular age that's the
language from a canadian philosopher
named charles taylor he calls it a
secular age
and uh you know we're kind of immersed
in that world
and so i think um one of the the
striking things and kind of the strange
things
as we read the bible um
is is just how kind of profoundly um
somewhat different
than our kind of view of the cosmos like
it's operating like it's sort of
assumptions about the world
about the created order it's quite
different and so um and really when i
say different i mean it's just how kind
of profoundly spiritual
um it is
now you might say well of course it's
the bible i spiritual of course i expect
it to be spiritual but i don't by
spiritual i don't just mean kind of like
well you know the bible talks a lot
about religious ideas you know or
theology or something or it says god a
lot um
by by spiritual um i i think i mean
um
it's
it's sort of um it's view of the cosmos
is that it's just shot through with
divinity it's shot through with with
spirit with the the spirit of god it's
um
what what some people call it is our
cosmology it's sort of our view of the
cosmos or i should say the new testament
view of the cosmos is like i mean it's
sort of god um as the source of all and
then um there's all sorts of kind of
like beings and there's the angelic and
the demonic and um
you know even there's paul uses some of
the language of principalities and
powers um which are kind of vague i mean
we don't really know exactly but it's
sort of forces of good forces of evil
and then that comes all the way down to
the created order and so the new
testament's kind of assumption and
apparently on this passage jesus
assumption is that like oh yeah that's
real
you know and i think that's where for us
as kind of modern listeners we're just
sort of like well
i don't always know what to do with that
at least for some of us maybe you know
many might be just like oh of course um
but for some it's sort of like i don't
know is that like
how literal do i take you know all this
house this like they're like really you
know the demons i grew up um in a
kind of the wing of the wing of the
church that was very into all this and
so i remember as like a 12 year old
reading these frank peretti novels if
you've ever read like piercing the
darkness i think is one and something
else darkness this present darkness he
was always in the darkness thing so um
and it was like about the demons and
like how they're influencing and like
you know they have like scales on their
back and hairy backs and like and they
would breathe and it was like phosphorus
you know i mean it was a very elaborate
kind of thing um
and
to be clear um i'm not necessarily kind
of advocating for precisely you know
those that sort of level of detail here
like the demons have hairy backs and you
know it's sort of like okay i don't know
um but i think we could kind of swing
the pendulum though and just be like
well that's stupid
you know and kind of be really leaving
the world
and assumptions of
like christ and the bible sort of behind
and then wondering why christian faith
makes zero sense to us
right because we sort of like let we
sort of jettison all that and then we're
kind of like huh well this doesn't make
any sense anymore you know i mean like
why did jesus have to die why did you
know i mean like all of a sudden it's
sort of we're kind of floundering and i
think um kind of what i'm getting at is
there is a certain um
there's a certain story we've just been
immersed in
as modern people and it's it's kind of
the story of a secular age which is
basically you know the cosmos all that
is
is just
things you know it's it's stuff you can
see it's stuff you can touch it or or um
measure
or um see or hear or you know something
you can engage with with the senses it's
almost like um
you know science sort of like hundreds
of years ago scientists said like okay
we're gonna study the world and so we're
gonna kind of bracket out
everything you can't you know measure
see taste touch hear
interact with in some way we're just
going to bracket it out and just for our
purposes we need to do some tests and so
that's what we're going to deal with or
things in this bracket that's we're
going to deal with a few hundred years
passes and people forgot that that was
like just a conscious decision it was
sort of a practical decision
and then say all that is
is what's in those brackets
can you see how like what one generation
is like well of course god spirit
all the you know but just for our
purposes of science we're just kind of
limiting ourselves to this but of course
we still believe you know but then a few
hundred years passes and then it's just
all that is the brackets so kind of what
i'm getting at um is that we now fast
forward 3 400 years we've been um kind
of as a culture
somewhat immersed in that in those
waters
the waters of
the cosmos is just bits of matter and
things now of course we're kind of like
well no brad i don't believe that i'm
not like you know an atheist or
something so i think the cosmos more
like i believe in god and that's what's
kind of interesting is that as
christians often what we do is
we sort of go with that guiding
assumption of all that is is sort of
like this is the cosmos it's just what
you can see what you can measure what
you can interact that is everything that
is and then we say but also god and so
we kind of tack him onto that story
you know sort of like also that and what
we end up with is what's called deism
this is the idea that there was sort of
some god being that like created
everything
and then was like
so long everyone
and off into the ether he went
never to return like
and i think it's sort of strange but
this is often how christians now like we
kind of somewhat at least at a practical
level it's almost like if you asked us
to articulate or what we believe we
wouldn't necessarily say it like that
but if you look at how we live
like that's sort of our guiding thing
it's kind of like we're just here alone
but occasionally we go to church to kind
of like build a little bridge to god
you know and kind of like oh okay
now it's my god moment and then i go
back to a sort of um
practical
kind of um day in day out um atheism in
a way
does this are you guys kind of tracking
with me am i i hope i'm not losing you
with this elaborate story um
and in other words the like we've been
kind of immersed in a culture that
really does view the world as like this
sort of dead cosmos and that's just
extremely different
than the bible that's extremely
different than as you saw luke chapter 4
verses 1-13
which says i don't know there's like
there's much more um going
on now um
another thing that's interesting is
we i think we kind of assume like well
that's just you know this sort of
guiding story that's in our culture we
just sort of assume it's true
and we even have kind of somewhat snobby
ways of viewing other cultures in the
past frankly i mean honestly every other
human culture that's like ever existed
on the planet like 20 000 years of human
culture they all believe not necessarily
they wouldn't use the exact same
language right but basically at the end
of the day they were saying there's
something more
right like
god spirit
um the angelic the demonic the a lot of
times they use the term the gods you
know it was like lowercase g gods you
know and christianity we would just call
them angels demons right they're like
there's something more going on here
and um
it's interesting that we kind of step
back from them and we have ways of
talking about them you know we say those
are well those were you know those were
primitive cultures that's sometimes our
language you know they were they were
primitive they were like they're like
little baby cultures they're like little
beginners
and then you know we grew up
those and this is often how we even view
people who like wrote the bible you know
what i mean like well they were those
they were so superstitious like they'd
believe anything you told them
they weren't educated like us
right can you kind of see some of the
angle like kind of how we think and
here's what's fascinating i think
probably
like in a similar way we look at them
we're like you guys you guys are kind of
idiotic i think they would probably look
at us
and just be like no
no you modern folks y'all are the
weirdos you're like you're the ones who
you can't walk into the forest anymore
like you've lost your spiritual sixth
sense you can't walk in there and sense
what we sensed
that there's something more in deeper
and profound terrifying and beautiful
going on here like you modern people i
think they say you walk in the forest
and you're like i mean it's kind of i go
here to relax
and you know
within a few minutes i'm kind of looking
around like wow
look at all this lumber
look at all
we get this place we could develop we
could put a strip mall here
you know this could really be you know
like this is sort of the strange way of
modern people like um like i think
they'd say you can't like you don't even
look at the stars anymore and say my god
how great thou art you're like oh we
actually know what those are those are
floating balls of gas millions of miles
away hanging magically in the air
you know like so we like it's like we ex
we almost explain it all away
and they're like don't you like
can't you see that the world as jared
manly hopkins said the world is charged
with the grandeur of god
i get shot through his spirit shot
through with divinity it's a profoundly
mysterious place
but but as modern people it's sort of
like
we don't really live in that kind of
world anymore
it's sort of disenchanted for us
you know we just sort of drained
god and spirit and
like we sort of drained it all out
and then we wonder why our lives feel
meaningless
because we've lost the story
we've lost the story like if it really
is true it's just bits of matter bumping
into one another and
it's just you live you die
turn into worm food i've actually seen
people online like talking about how you
know humans really just like meat suits
like i've used that language i mean just
meat suits you know this is my meat suit
it's like
now it's kind of funny i mean i get like
the language like you know but that's
actually um
like if you really take that idea and
start running with it like
that's like a really sad view of the
world
you know
and you know um it's not just though
just like intuitions of this there's
also experiences i think as we think of
like
you know um these folks who aren't all
the other human cultures in the world
that said something more is going on you
know as we think it wasn't just that
they kind of vaguely intuited the divine
they also had experiences
and those experiences
led them to certain stories and
conclusions right and honestly here's
what's interesting as modern people if
you actually talk with people
um
not all but many people have had
experiences too
experiences of things seen things they
can't explain
sensing things they can't explain how
did i know that how did i know that
thing or like here's a classic one is uh
the sense out of nowhere someone's
hurting someone's in me someone i love
is in trouble
you call
sure enough they're in the hospital
it's like
right and we don't have like in our view
of the world we don't have an x split
well you don't have any way of know now
you could say like well it's just it's
science we just don't know how it works
yet or i mean maybe maybe
but it could just be that and it doesn't
fit in our little view of things
right and so we kind of are forced to
just explain it away but that's what's
interesting the more you have to explain
away
the more it makes me wonder do we just
need a better
a better story do we need a better
understanding of
the world the cosmos um
so so that's that's first i want to kind
of nudge us again i'm not trying to get
overly elaborate here get us all super
paranoid be in the church that sees
demons around absolutely every corner
you know um
you know your wrist starts hurting
that's the demon of wrist pain you know
or something like
i'm not trying to get us there but i
just think there's just a temptation for
us as modern people in the modern world
to really swing that pendulum so much
that it's like we're just kind of
functional atheists who then believe in
god and jesus
kind of at a certain level but it's like
in our bodies in our living we don't
really kind of don't you know
so that's that's first
first thing to remember we don't live
like we don't inhabit this dead cosmos
but it's like pulsing it's live it's a
deeper more mysterious place than we
tend to
think
um okay so that's first second thing to
remember um remember you have a battle
to fight
remember you have a battle to fight as
we um saw in our scripture reading for
today jesus
had this experience with the devil the
the demonic
and it was a it was a spiritual battle
right he faced temptation and actually
if you've ever read any of the gospels
matthew mark luke john you can't read
like five pages
without jesus encountering
some form of spiritual resistance in the
form of of like the demonic it's just i
mean it just happens over and over and
over
um
and and so i think um
you know so part of our understanding
is to then say okay so our understanding
of the cosmos has room for that and
understands there's there's some sort of
battle going on here between the forces
of good and the forces of evil again
what other religions would probably use
language of the gods lower case gods we
kind of use the language of the angelic
the demonic um
and i think in this sense
there's like there is a i'm not trying
to sound melodramatic but um
there is in a sense like a certain
battle for our soul in other words for
who we are becoming
because we're either living in a way
that's bringing heaven to earth
or
not right we're living a way that's like
bringing um hell
to earth and um
i think this is where even kind of basic
things
like like spiritual practices you know
whether it's prayer scripture reading um
attending worship you know again in our
kind of modern world
we kind of because we have a certain
view of the world a certain story that
we're telling ourselves about it and it
really is sort of drained of anything
about the spirit and such and you know
god and those realms the unseen realm
because we don't believe in that then
really this coming here even i mean kind
of makes sense but kind of not
right it's almost like a somewhat cutesy
nice to have
you know like like worshiping or praying
or reading the scriptures or you know
engaging lent or like all of that it's
sort of like oh that's adorable good for
you you do that you do that you like
that i unless you like that story that's
good for you you know um but we but our
story doesn't necessarily um totally
make sense of it when you see this
bigger story that jesus assumes that the
new testament assumes then it makes more
sense we're bringing our own
lives into alignment with the good the
beautiful the true
with who god is
and
um
and in this sense i think anyone for
example who's really struggled with
addiction
can tell like
you're we're both and i mean like
like legit
addiction like that will just drag you
down to the pit you know just terrible
places
um
like uh
use can sense
that there's there's like yes certain
biology right certain things happen like
probably just you know brain and we're
humans and there's certain things going
on and yet we can also you might have
started to sense the spiritual side to
it right this is what it means to be
human is like both were material or
physical and spiritual
right that would be the story that would
be the guiding assumption
of the bible it's like you're both
physical material and spiritual
and i think in addiction that's an
instance where people can start to feel
like whoa is there like something else
going on here
there's a a guy i came across his name's
richard gallagher
he's
he wrote a wonderful little article for
the washington post this is maybe the
best article title of all time he said
uh
uh well actually before i read it i
should i should mention i realized i may
be shooting some of your wheels off
tonight and uh
that's okay you know
you feel free to disagree by the way
it's okay um i should mention as a as a
christian a few years ago like i do
understand there's a certain you know
like there's a certain way of being
christian that doesn't necessarily it
sort of doesn't go in for all of that
you know i mean that sees sort of the
devil
the demonic all that as sort of
metaphors for sin for temptation for
evil you know and like hey i've been
there like i don't know 10 years ago or
something i was there so and being a
christian you know so i'm not trying to
say like if you don't agree with every
word i'm saying you're not even you're
not a true christian you know no no
there's room so
don't want to freak out too much having
said that
um that's that's not quite where i'm now
so i want to always be honest with y'all
so uh so this guy richard gallagher he
wrote uh
he's a fascinating guy i like that blue
blazer he's got there um
but he wrote uh so he's a board
certified he's a psychiatrist professor
professor of clinical psychiatry at new
york medical college he wrote this is
the best article title um as
a psychiatrist i diagnose mental illness
also i helped spot demonic possession
that was the title of this washington
post
and uh and here's and again i know i
might be shooting some of your wheels
out here like brett has he's jumped the
shark this is where he loses it guys um
but uh so he basically for 30 years he's
been you know clinical psychiatrist and
he says like 99.9 of the folks i help
it's just like you know run-of-the-mill
normal mental illness stuff like just
you know um
but he's basically been uh he's like a
consultant for um the catholic church in
the vatican
and they bring him in
um partly because they
at least certain priests they don't want
to like fall into kind of a certain you
know almost a raving fundamentalism that
does see that demons are in everything
and everyone and you know and so they
want to be careful before
you know it's kind of looking at someone
and kind of trying to go the you know
exorcism route basically and so they
bring him in as a consulting
physician
and to say whether no this is mental
illness or
not
and so he writes this article um i think
he's written a book as well after 30
years of kind of reflecting on all this
and he's basically kind of someone who i
think started off in one story of the
world and through his experiences
shifted his story and it's kind of like
yeah most of the time it's just you know
normal mental illness but sometimes oh
my god i mean the story the stories he
tells him it's you know there's a reason
horror movies kind of draw their
inspiration often from at least they
claim you know kind of real life
accounts and things um
and he says in this stuff he's seen a
little old lady you know
like it's super frail and all of a
sudden it's the classic you know the
face changes the voice changes pixies
picked one of the priests up chucks them
across the room you know it's like
what is start speaking fluent in latin
you know and saying horrible things to
the pre-snow latin so they're like oh
that's that's not good what she's saying
right now that's not good at all
[Laughter]
and so he's he's like look i mean you
can sail you're crazy you're a liar
you're what he's like i've just
i'm there i don't know what else to say
you know
um
or even think of like pentecostalism the
fastest growing segment in the world of
christianity like the fastest growing
wing
and um
why i think because
it's a story that aligns especially
outside the west because right again in
our west we got our western kind of
secular age that's what we're living in
but in the rest of the world they're not
like us
they're like nope we're not the weirdos
y'all are the weirdos you know
and uh
and so in their experience this is the
world they
inhabit and so they want a version of
christianity that actually speaks to
that
right instead of just kind of like
sweeping under the rug or saying you're
you know an idiot or something
um
so that's a second um remember you have
a battle
to fight and um
all right third want to keep moving
third remember your greatest weapon is a
heart posture of
surrender
greatest weapon is a heart posture of
surrender you know after a message like
this i can imagine i don't know i don't
know i'm fascinated by the things going
on in people's heads right now who knows
um
but i think maybe there's a certain
segment that could be quite freaked out
like oh my gosh
what this stuff is real there's a blood
i have no categories for this and now
i'm freaking out and um i want to be
clear there's a beautiful passage this
is james 4 7 says submit yourselves then
to god
resist the devil and he will flee from
you
and the way i interpret that is not that
um
submitting yourself to god and resisting
the devil are like two separate things
i don't think so i think
surrender submission to god like that is
spiritual warfare
that is
what we need to do in other words um
you know if
if you want to anoint all of your
doorposts with
olive oil from jerusalem
or um
you know leave worship music playing in
every room of your house um or where
crucifix you know to protect yourself or
like you're okay sure i mean that's fine
i hear it like works
whether you believe it or not you know
what i mean so go for it um
but at the end of the day i'm not
necessarily trying to push us all into
there i'm what i'm saying is like we
need to just um
the the best thing we can do is
live a life of love and surrender of god
god who is father-son spirit like
that's the best thing we can do
and it's like they say um
it's a little bit cliche but i think
it's cliche because it's true that the
safest place to be is like in the in the
hands of god you know that's of course a
metaphor for like staying in alignment
with who got us
staying in alignment i think at the end
of the day we don't need to become
obsessed with the demonic and the
angelic and like ranking the demons you
know and people have elaborate you can
go online and find all sorts of
angelologies and what kind of angel
corresponds to what demon and fights you
know it's like at the end of the day i
mean i'll just be completely honest i
have next to no interest in any of that
um
because i want the table to like we're
following jesus right
we're focused we're focusing there
um and and i think at the end of the day
like that's you know submission
um
surrender like that is warfare that is
resisting the devil that's all you need
to do we don't need some elaborate you
know class on demonology um
loving god that's i think that's
enough
so as we um come to the table you
probably saw we have communion tonight
um i want to just you know remind us
that again this isn't some sort of uh
cutesy adorable little christian ritual
um you know we we really believe like
the holy spirit is present
and something beautiful and powerful is
happening in this space as we learn to
love one another as we learn to love god
and as we take this in this this bread
um
this this juice like it's it's uh it's
not only symbolic right it is it's it's
physical it's material and it's
spiritual right the very act is
surrender the very act is submission to
god it's bringing ourselves into
alignment
and so i encourage you to um think of it
in that way
so this um
this practice of communion goes way back
to the very night jesus was betrayed he
had one final meal with his disciples
and during that meal at one point he
stood up and he held up a loaf of bread
and then he broke it and he said this is
my body broken for you
and then he held up a cup of wine
and he said this is my blood shed for
you
whenever you eat this bread whenever you
drink this cup remember me
and so for 2000 years now
christians have come to the table to
take in to connect through the holy
spirit to connect with
the crucified and risen one
and so that's the sacrament that's the
the ritual that we're partaking in
tonight um here at the table we practice
what's called um an open table meaning
if you're here tonight and you want to
participate
then you're welcome to
no one's like checking your theological
credentials
you know if you would like to connect
with christ then you're welcome to come
forward having said that there's no
stigma if you feel like you're not in a
place where you're you want to do that
that's fine um there's no judgment
um
which i should also mention it is
gluten-free bread for anyone concerned
about such things
so let me go ahead and invite you to the
table this is a celtic christian
invitation
it says this is the table
not of the church
but of the lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more
so come
you who have much faith
and you who have little
you who have been here often
and you who have not been here long
you who have tried to follow
and you who have failed
come
come because it's the lord himself who
invites you
and it is his will that those who want
to meet him should meet him here
come to the table
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
jesse's gonna sing this song it's called
belovedness and um
i just
i found it to be
such a powerful
message
and i hope you find it to be the same
for you so you guys just feel free to
sit
and take in these lyrics
and i feel like what brett was saying
just about being in alignment
with god and who he says we are
this is that moment you know to realign
to listen to his voice hear it speak
love and
acceptance over you
[Music]
you've owned your fear
and all your self-loathing
you've owned the voices inside of your
head
you've on the shame and reproach of your
failure
it's time to own your belovedness
you've owned your past and now it's to
find you you've owned everything
everybody
else says
it's time to hear what your father has
spoken
it's time to own your belovedness
and he says you're mine i smiled when i
made you
i find you beautiful in every way
my love for you is fierce and unending
i'll come to find you whatever it takes
[Music]
you've owned your mess
you've seen in the mirror
you've owned the lies that you're just
not enough
you've been so blinded by
it's time to own your beloved
[Music]
and he says you're mine
i smiled when i made you
you're fine you're beautiful in every
way
my love for you
is fierce and unending
i'll come to find you whatever it takes
my beloved
it's time to own your
[Music]
beloved you are completely
loved and fully known
beloved
died to make your heart
his home
he says you're mine i smiled when i made
you
i find you beautiful in every way
my love for you
is fierce and unending
i'll come to find you whatever
[Music]
and he says you're mine i smiled when i
made you
i find you beautiful in every way
my love for you
is fierce and unending
i'll come to find you whatever it takes
[Music]
it's
join me in prayer please
lord jesus
may we adamantly
in your strength
disown
all those things not of you that have
been said to us about us and from us
and may we in your strength
just instinctively
begin to own
all that the father has spoken over us
all that the father has revealed
in us through you
may we fiercely own those things that
are of you
thank you father
i want to again remind you that we are
always available immediately after the
service here to pray with you if you
have specific needs you'd like to have
the prayer of agreement
that's one of my favorite things to do
so please take advantage of that
opportunity if there's something we can
stand with you agree with you
lay hands upon you concerning tonight
i want to
encourage visitors to fill out the
welcome card back here just by the
little box on the outside of this door
back here
also i want to remind you to come up to
the let me get the name of it because i
never remember the name of the place hat
creek burger
just after the service tonight let's go
straight up there
and let me say this too please do not
stay away because you are
financially
unable i'll buy your dinner
i promise
if you'll come and you need of finances
just get in touch with me or maryland
and we'll buy your dinner
we'd love to have you there we'd love to
have the opportunity to get to know you
and for
others now maryland are not going to go
up there right after as quickly while
they clean up here but we will be there
and you can look for us
and then um
[Music]
because i've encouraged you to fill out
the welcome card have i not yes i have
all right that's good i did that one
okay according according to the script
uh if you'd stand i want to uh
put a new twist on the benediction
tonight a little bit
because we talk here and
rightfully so about positioning
ourselves
to receive the
and we
have a posture that we've become
familiar with a physical posture
i talked a little bit last time about
having a mental and emotional posture as
well
but what i'm going to do with this
tonight is i'm just going to flip it
over
and i'm going to let you hear yourself
speaking to yourself
this quick blessing so i'm going to ask
you to just repeat after me
all right
i am included in the eternal life of the
father son and holy spirit
i have always been included
i have never been excluded
i was included
from before time began
my incl
was the will and purpose of the father
and i will become secure in the
knowledge of my inclusion
amen
you're dismissed
[Music]
and he says you're mine i smiled when i
made you
i find you beautiful in every way
my love for you
is fierce and unending i'll come to find
you whatever it takes
he says you're mine
i smiled when i made you
i find you beautiful in every way
my love for you
is fierce and unending
i'll come to find you whatever it takes
[Music]
it's